DOLLARS AND HE BETTER HANG ONTO
THAT CASH BECAUSE HE MADE NEEDED
FOR HIS CRIMINAL DEFENSE.
>> Sean: AMAZING.
GREAT REPORTING.
THANK YOU, GREGG.
THANK YOU, DACA R.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PRAISED THE
COOPERATION BETWEEN FRANCE AND
THE UNITED STATES STANDING UP TO
THE MULLAHS IN TORONTO AND
FIGHTING ISIS RADICALS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> FRANCE IN THE UNITED STATES
ALSO AGREE THAT IRAN CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO DEVELOP A NUCLEAR
WEAPON.
THAT REGIME MUST END ITS SUPPORT
OF TERRORISTS.
ALL OVER, NO MATTER WHERE YOU GO
IN THE MIDDLE EAST, YOU SEE THE
FINGERPRINTS OF IRAN BEHIND
PROBLEMS.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK
PRESIDENT MACRON FOR FRANCE'S
VITAL CONSERVATION TO OUR VERY
SUCCESSFUL CAMPAIGN AGAINST
ISIS.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT AND FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN
GORKA AND NRA TV CONTRIBUTOR,
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT, DAN
BONGINO.
ALL ACROSS ASIA, YOU SEE THESE
RELATIONSHIPS, PRIME MINISTER OF
JAPAN, PRESIDENT OF CHINA
CAPITULATING ON INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY RIGHTS, ON TRADE, ON
AUTOMOBILES, ON TARIFFS.
YOU SEE WHAT WAS UNSPEAKABLE,
DR. GORKA, AN AMAZING ALLIANCE
TO COMBAT IRANIAN HEGEMONY
BETWEEN UNITED STATES, ISRAEL,
SAUDIS, THE EMIRATES,
JORDANIANS, EGYPTIANS.
UNTHINKABLE IN THE OBAMA YEARS.
>> YEAH, AND ALL OF THIS IN JUST
15 MONTHS.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE HAS
ACHIEVED.
WE HAVE NATO, WE HAVE THE FRENCH
PRIME MINISTER WITHIN MINUTES OF
MEETING THE PRESIDENT ON THE
STATE VISIT SAYING YOU WANT US
TO SPEND MORE ON OUR DEFENSE,
STOP BEING FREELOADERS?
YOU'VE GOT IT.
THE NATO SECRETARY GENERAL HAS
DONE THE SAME.
THAT'S AFTER DECADES OF
FREELOADING INSIDE NATO.
WE HAVE SEEN ISIS DECIMATED IN
TERMS OF THE PHYSICAL CALIPHATE.
WE HAVE SEEN ALL OF OUR FRIENDS
AND ALLIES REASSURED IN ASIA AND
IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF RESULTS
YOU WOULD BE PROUD OF AS THE
PRESIDENT AT THE END OF YOUR
SECOND TERM, MAY BE AT THE END
OF YOUR FIRST TERM BUT NOT AT
THE END OF YOUR VERY, VERY FIRST
TERM.
JUST THE IDEA THAT SUNNI STATES,
ARAB SUNNI STATES ARE NOW
COOPERATING HAND IN GLOVE WITH
ISRAEL TO DEAL WITH THE THREAT
OF JIHADI VIOLENCE.
IT'S STUNNING.
>> Sean: IT'S INTERESTING.
AS THE PRESIDENT ISOLATED
NORTH KOREA, WE SAW, DAN
BONGINO, WHAT THE NORTH KOREANS
DID.
THE GOOD RELATIONSHIP
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS WEAK
PRESIDENT OF CHINA.
THAT PLAYED A BIG PART IN ALL OF
THIS.
ACQUIESCING ON MAJOR ISSUES.
NOW YOU SEE THE SAME THING
HAPPENING, THE ALLIANCE CREATED
AGAINST THE IRANIAN MULLAHS.
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN
BACKING UP 150 BILLION IN CASH
AND OTHER CURRENCIES AND CARGO
PLANES.
>> YEAH, SEAN, I THINK ONE OF
TRUMP'S ASSETS HAS BEEN HIS
UNPAID DEBILITY.
YOU CAN CHALK THAT UP TO
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
THE LEFT-LEANING HACKS AND THE
MEDIA HAVE BEEN TAKING POT SHOTS
AT TRUMP AND HIS FOREIGN POLICY
FOREVER.
SEBASTIAN IS RIGHT.
THEY MOCKED HIM OVER HIS
APPROACH TO NATO UNTIL THESE
COUNTRY STARTED MAKING LARGER
COMMITMENTS TO NATO.
THEY MOCKED HIM OVER HIS
APPROACH TO NORTH KOREA.
OH, HE'S GOING TO GET US INTO
NUCLEAR WAR.
NOW THEY NORTH KOREANS ARE
COMING TO THE TABLE WITH AT
LEAST TALKS.
I DON'T WANT TO OVERSELL IT, FOR
DENUCLEARIZATION.
YOU CAN'T DENY THE FACT, SEAN,
THAT HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA, THE ECONOMIC PRESSURE HE
PUT ON CHINA DUE TO HIS TERROR
THREAT, PROBABLY HAD SOME THING
TO DO WITH IT.
HONESTLY, IT IS SAD AS AN
AMERICAN TO WATCH THE MEDIA, NOT
ALL OF THEM.
THERE ARE A FEW OF COME AROUND A
LITTLE BIT ON THIS BUT MOST OF
THEM JUST CONTINUE TO MOCK THIS
GUY AS SOME KIND ABOUT THE PHONE
AS HE RUNS RINGS ABOUT WHAT
OBAMA DID IN EIGHT YEARS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH.
INCREDIBLE NIGHT, INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE WORLD.
APPEASEMENT NEVER WORKS.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH WORKS.
AGAIN, WE SIDE WITH NEVILLE
CHAMBERLAIN VERSUS
WINSTON CHURCHILL.
ALL OF THE PEOPLE AGAINST
RONALD REAGAN, AND WE SEE IT